en exposant une sélection des oeuvres
d'edward debat-ponsan le musée des
beaux-arts de tours révèle un peu du
patrimoine artistique de la touraine
près de 80 tableaux du classicisme
officiel à l'orée de l'impressionnisme
retrace l'évolution d'un peintre un
artiste qui s'est installée en touraine
à nazelles en 1900
les le grand père de michel et d'olivier
debré ce grand artiste qui a marqué en
fait toute une génération par sa
peinture abstraite et qui disait très
joliment en fait qu'il était très très
marquée par l'art de son grand-père et
disait même mon grand-père était
impressionnistes et moi je suis abstrait
bien sûr mais j'essaye par le biais de
l'abstraction d'exprimer l'impression
que j'ai devant un paysage je trouve que
c'est très joli et ça montre bien le
fils je dirais artistique qu'il y ait en
fait les deux hommes avec ce tableau la
vérité sortant du puits
edouard debat-ponsan prend parti en
faveur de dreyfus
c'est cette prise de position qui
l'obligent à se retirer en touraine et
c'est avec la douceur tourangelle que
son pinceau va se libérer les phénomènes
loire en lui-même le paysage de la loire
avec ses bancs de sable avec ceux avec
ce court très larges incite évidemment
des images complètement différente pas
du tout les chais donc il va ça va
trouver une palette plus douce est une
manière de peindre plus allusive par
petites touches avec des touches de
couleurs pures qui se rapproche
énormément de la sensibilité
impressionniste qui a quand même à la
fin du 19ème vraiment acquis
t
ce parcours de l'académisme du xviiie à
une forme d'impressionnisme est à
découvrir jusqu'au 15 février au musée
des beaux-arts de tours